quality boilerplate whirring singing
yeah and they hired me my role on that
show was they needed like a young dumb
[ __ ] that was willing to get wasted
you're like oh you're perfect in the
wrong Germany on the show he was yeah
Troy was on the shut up so I would I did
I was on are you kidding me or what c.c.
deville Tuesday afternoon [ __ ]
well I had your Lola ACDC Lisa add a
couple bong hits some [ __ ] edibles of
death here we're going deep tonight with
the transmission field
this is transmission room this is
definitely [ __ ] trans look at this
here
smoke [ __ ] [ __ ] you think she's gonna
step outside Alana get no secondary
smoke she's trying to put it together
snow Mahanama like us yes she used to be
though she used to be a [ __ ] animal
[Music]
but you get oh the [ __ ] am i doing my
life if you're under 18 hang up now
[ __ ] I know you're wondering about
the new hairdo gotta go for the audition
for a [ __ ] guy from the 70s nobody
[ __ ] up close in the 70s nobody like
dress up like the 70s
I'll put the hairdo 17:01 thing if you
just something about a costume audition
you ain't getting that row you ain't
good
I've seen it for years [ __ ]
dress up like chefs is [ __ ] you're in no
[ __ ] Genki you might as well [ __ ]
put in the ten dollars and join
Scientology and get roles that will ease
things transmission fluid coming your
way
Skywalker which is really look ease Girl
Scout cookies and [ __ ] Larry out of
[ __ ] talking laughs and that's it
well he pees with the party started
[ __ ] yeah and that's it and that's that
those days a good day
nobody's doing dick on Tuesday if we
come smell this anymore
that's not transmission then you get
deep in this [ __ ] clip of THC and
debt you bite this [ __ ] and
you're afraid for the best young Sam
this could be a gummy bear this could be
a cosmic pill this could be anything at
this point and we'll split knees
understand
oh yeah as they say in Europe muchas
muchas play this thing I'm falling apart
[Music]
the oil the greasy oily like that you're
going down Jack down to the ground
[ __ ] you're going down I'm
telling you a little hug woman and I ski
here a few bomblets then we're ready to
go look the cops know we're here [ __ ]
them - and the words NWA
[ __ ] the police they do nothing wait
transmission fluid they don't wanna know
that I love the new head she's blowing
[ __ ] heat chasing
I've never seen women that didn't stop
drinking yes if you're a woman and
you're 32 stop [ __ ] drinkin out cuz it
don't go no better than this yeah it
goes from 38 to 46 real quick what
happens and you do blow when you jumble
up and down and you think everybody's
beautiful [ __ ] that [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] it was one of those nights when
you turn off the lights [ __ ] what's
matter you get flashes already yeah
we'll do a few bunnies together like
family
and then we'll [ __ ] start the show
violet the Bombardier [ __ ] [ __ ] you
in the smoke alarm with long deep
tonight I told you if you're under 18
hang up now too long grandma calling me
speaking of Grandma she's always got new
pills in the [ __ ] cabinet go red have
capped out that foot pill no thank you
for a ride with a [ __ ] with a Bloody
Mary you think that foot pill it's all
over Jack they will see you till next
Tuesday
you know grandma's always got some type
of gun grandma tells you she takes pills
for a dizziness that's good enough for
me
you take two of those in the cocktail or
two you'll feel the effects more you
won't feel your foot I dig it looking
[ __ ] up is for [ __ ] facts okay I
don't look up nothing you [ __ ] take
it like I told you I found one allow
these pills in Vegas and up I swear the
guy's my wife had washed it yeah and it
was still the numbers who washed off I
broke that pill in half and inhaled that
[ __ ] and you take your chances
absolutely take your chances and they're
gonna kill you the worst in me you might
stop breathing for 10 minutes lips lose
an eye is something gonna kill my second
expired pills they're the best
you bring me expired pill I'll give you
a double-faced Valley
Chuchu stifle Lisa at business favorite
[Music]
refocus whose day were here with
chitchat and sometimes that's the most
important thing it's just a little
Tecate yeah we got a big over here
listen either go big or go home you know
who said that Pablo Escobar after he
blew up a [ __ ] plane alright go big
or go home
he blew up a [ __ ] place so you think
about that if you're gonna do something
do it big all right
stop wasting your time dilly-dally
hanging out with your buddies at the
stand
none there ain't none understand but a
bunch of people lying to one another
here we go here we go
here we go oh [ __ ] there's a young Angus
Young
grab the tray from the Chinese
restaurant bones and you always got to
bring home the tray these things are
good for sup
[ __ ] them little brown [ __ ] patties
here we go here we go
American Express don't leave home
without it
Jack seconds what's in your wallet
contract wreath the looks zoom you
always handsome ready joints we release
this is the one breathe out your nose we
see you don't kill yourself
oh [ __ ] look at least I am yeah we
[ __ ] around no more you see what
training does and the word Joey Diaz
keep showing up [ __ ] back in ten
minutes
YouTube top slash done youtube.com slash
c / Joey this will take a little it oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]